if you had the power to go back in time
and stop the deaths of your loved ones
what would you do a killer is trying to
brutally murder everyone you know across
space and time and no one can stop him
except you I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the Future Past killer in erased
this guy has no idea that everyone he
loves is going to die satoro here is
your below average achiever with an
insane power he goes to his second job
as a pizza delivery boy when all of a
sudden his powers activate suddenly
sensing something is wrong inside of
this truck he follows it calling out to
the driver but he doesn't respond he
then sees a kid crossing the street
about to be murdered and he forces the
truck to make a turn crashing into this
car and he saves another life satoru has
the power to go back minutes into the
past and is able to predict the near
future because of this but it's going to
cost him big after saving the kid and a
trip to the hospital to treat his
injuries so Toro finally reaches home
and runs into his mother he finds out
that she's come to stay with him while
he gets better great nice to have you
here Mom satoru reluctantly agrees and
the two go shopping but that's when
satoru's powers activate again and he
tells his mother that something
terrifying is about to happen unless he
stops it his mother comments that he
used to act like this when he was a
child but she never knew why the two-day
alert just as the mother notices a
strange man with glasses holding a
child's hand as they head to his car
suspicious this glasses guy gets into
his car but then leaves the child alone
as he drives off without her having a
gut feeling soro's mother quickly tries
to take a picture of the guy's license
plate and later mentions to satoru that
she's certain they've just prevented a
kidnapping she reveals to him that what
just happened just now is like what
happened way back when satoru was just a
kid 18 years ago when three kidnappings
and murders happened in this very town
and the true murderer was never caught
at least according to what she thinks
later back at home she warns satoru to
be careful out there as it likely won't
be long before this kidnapper strikes
again and she has no idea just how right
she is the next day sat's mother begins
to realize that she's just seen the face
of the kidnapper before but she can't
remember from where she does some
research and begins to suspect that the
kidnapper from yesterday likely
committed the murders that happened in
the town she lived in 18 years ago
piecing the clues together she finally
thinks she knows who the murderer really
is just as she hears her son arriving
home prepared to tell him the good news
she turns around to greet him but that's
when she gets murdered and silenced for
good moments later satoru finally
reaches home and passes by a strange man
on his way into his apartment seeing his
door unlocked he discovers his mother's
corpse right in front of him as his
neighbor accidentally sees everything
and calls the police forcing satoru to
run scared and Afraid his powers
activate waking up he realizes that he's
been sent back 18 years in the past the
same year that the three murders in his
town took place
1988 okay while this may seem crazy this
could have been explained by the same
thing that basically created Wolverine
it's clear before this that satoru had
the ability to travel minutes back into
the past we know it also allows him to
see a few minutes into the future which
is really cool however what makes this
situation just now even more horrifying
is that he's never traveled this far
back in time this is brand new but it
likely has something to do with a thing
known as latent genetics if DNA is
essentially a bunch of molecules that
contain instructions on how to make up a
species like you and me then a latent
Gene is a gene that is already present
within someone's DNA structure but has
not yet been activated or is doing
anything it's just sitting there
chilling if this Gene could be awakened
by various genetic mechanisms and or
through other means it could be possible
that when satoro here just saw his
mother die and reemed the three deaths
that happened when he was a kid both of
these traumatic events happening around
the same time likely triggered soro's
lay in ability to travel back in time
further than he's ever traveled before
just like how Wolverine first discovered
his power after he saw his parents get
killed right in front of him it's
important to know though it also can
mean that his powers are going to be
more powerful than he thinks that is why
we need to understand our powers better
because it will give us the safety net
we need in case we mess up and we need
to possibly reload to an earlier safe
point if you know what I mean now a
10-year-old school boy satoru is
horrified at what just happened he's
never gone back so far in time before
and so he runs out of school to check on
his mother realizing she's still alive
he celebrates but becomes determined to
stop the kidnapper in the past from
killing his mom in the future he'll need
to find and stop this killer before he
murders three children within the next
few months the next day satoru goes to
school and notices one of the soon Tobe
murdered victims this little girl named
Kyle he spots a bruise on her leg and
that's when he remembers that before she
died she was going through something
really really bad he talks to his
childhood friends about Kyo and her
situation but his friends have no idea
that he just traveled from the future
and this one guy tells him to read the
school paper that Kyle recently wrote an
essay for and he discovers that her
essay is a cry for help to get away from
her abusive mother so tor's memory on
the past starts coming back as he
realizes that kyo's Mom was the reason
that Kyle always stayed late after
school and this is probably the reason
she's going to be murdered very soon
because she always stays at school late
no one's around she's alone with the
facts in place satoro prepares his plan
to save the first soon to be victim okay
well it may seem he has everything
figured out so Toro needs to consider
three very important theories to do with
time travel if you want to change Kaio
soon to be death or you're going to die
trying so Toro being able to go back in
time at all eliminates one popular
theory on why time travel is impossible
it is known as the Granda Paradox it
states that if you went back in time to
murder your grandparents this act alone
would change enough of your past that
would make you unable to travel to the
past in the first place since you
wouldn't exist however a second theory
that goes around this grandfather
paradox states that even if you Tred to
go back in time to stop something from
happening the end outcome would
ultimately still happen just in another
way trying to prevent your friend from
dying in a car crash he might just die
later on the train for example and
because satoro has time traveled it
could mean that even if he saves Kyle
the first time he might have to stick to
just like velcro all the freaking time
now the third and final theory that
could support sato's mission is one
known as the many worlds Theory it
suggest that there's infinite number of
universes out there with everything that
could happen has happened but these
universes never interact with each other
let's say for example art riter Dom has
a bunch of really nice watches in one
universe but according to this Theory
there's also a world where Dom doesn't
have a watch collection so sad or even
other universes or watches own a lot of
Doms and use him as a watch scary
basically the third Theory means that
each time so Toro goes back in time to
change the past he's essentially
creating a new timeline and traveling
back in time to a new timeline that he
altered and not his original and it's
this one that is the only one that makes
his time traveling Powers possible to
begin with now if I was him in order to
approach this situation he's got to
figure out the why behind it all kyo's
bru indicates that she has a hard Family
Life Kyo is a rayuse barely 10 years old
and this means that the only people who
have access to her intimately is her
mother and her mother's boyfriend the
school these are the only ones that
would be able to know kyo's schedule on
an intimate level I would first talk to
one of the school counselors since Japan
during the 1980s began to introduce them
into schools and would notify them of
kyo's parents neglecting her this would
likely do the trick enough to cause the
attention to shift onto Kyo in order to
hold her off from getting killed anytime
soon while we work on figuring out who
the Killer is since since by stopping
the killer now we'll also stop our mom's
death in the future if any of the time
travel theories happen to pan out satoro
follows CA one day after school to her
favorite Park the park where she will
soon be murdered he then awkwardly asks
if the two can become friends and Kyle
ends up liking sato's super weird
directness and he then invites her to
his upcoming birthday party since it's
well coming up knowing her murder will
take place right before her birthday
saturo the next day asks Kyle when her
birthday is so he can get ready for it
but she refuses to tell him now he's
annoyed so heads into the teacher's
office to look at her file just as his
class teacher Mr yoshiro catches him
snooping around satoro tells him that he
wants to know kyo's birthday and Mr
yoshiro Smiles telling him that kyo's
birthday is the same day as his meaning
that her murder will take place before
their birthday it means that satoro oh
has only 11 days to save her before
getting killed he then rushes to go find
Kyle but runs into his older friend and
one who will get accused of the soon to
be murders Yuki they go to hang out at
his house as Soro becomes even more
convinced that this guy is is not the
true killer and gets even more
determined to save him as well great
because we love to add more problems to
our list of things to do after that he
heads over to Kyle's house to check on
her but he discovers something
terrifying Kyle badly be up in a nearby
shed and he shocked to the Bone just as
Kyle's mother arrives and she shoves him
out of the way and drags Kyo back into
the house and saturo thinks her mother
could be the killer we now have N9 days
left until her death and sataro speeds
up his investigation and discovers from
his teacher yashiro that the school
knows about kyo's abuse and that they
can't do anything anything about it
unless she's caught in the act thinking
of a new plan he manages to convince
kyo's mother to hang out with him at a
museum during the weekend but there he
remembers that he actually bumped into
Kyo at this same Museum on this day 18
years ago purely by chance and he
realizes that while he's changing the
small details he's still repeating the
overall events of the past now we're on
to the next day with less than 24 hours
until her death sat Toro decides to pick
her up from school but this time watches
her the entire day even walking her home
after school and they pass by the very
same park that Kyle was going to be
murdered tonight changing the course of
history or so he thinks dropping her
home he waits the whole night outside of
her house until the next day in order to
make sure she's safe until morning and
what did you know if the sun rises and
he happily thinks he saved her and the
two hang out the whole day at school at
his birthday party after making it the
best day of his life and she waves him
goodbye after and he heads home and then
he sleeps off the fun without a care in
the world and he wakes up early the day
after and he heads to school at all but
notices Kyo isn't there and no one knows
where she is realizing that he only
pushed kyo's abduction by one day and
has changed nothing of the past at all
what did I tell you my people we just
proved our second time travel theory
that whatever was meant to happen will
happen the Kyo was always meant to die
or it could just mean that satoro here
was just an idiot ignoring the time
travel in general satoro here was way
too naive to think that saving K one
time would mean that she would be Sav
forever as I said before the killer that
murdered our mother was methodical and
knew where she was and when she was most
vulnerable and was able to kill her
without much effort facing the same
killer from the present as we are in the
past means that we should have assumed
that this killer would have been on Kyo
since the beginning since he's a pro
he's done this before it means that by
making sure Kyo avoided the park where
she was originally going to be killed
would have only delayed things this
killer would not give up that easily and
because like our mother kyo's death was
not random the victims were chosen based
on their daily routines that the killer
analyzed in advance it's not surprising
that the victim with a rocky family
situation was chosen to be killed the
killer was super aware of his victims
and knew everything about them he should
have considered altering or changing the
cir cumstances leading up to the kid's
death instead coming up from ideas from
this angle of thinking would have been
much better long term running out of
school he rushes to K's house but sees
no one home or in the shed and then he
notices adult-sized Footprints leading
out of it remembering that it snow 2
days ago this makes satoro figure out
that someone has been here since then
over the next few days the media works
on Sheltering the town's children from
the horrifying reality of what is really
going on sato's classmates get told by
the school that Kaa moved to her
grandmother's house in another city the
police continue to investigate everyone
but that's when another kid goes missing
and satoro quickly realizes that despite
minor changes the past is still
repeating itself and he needs to figure
out what to do passing by Kyle's house
again this time he sees her mother
throwing out kyo's clothes and almost
looking relieved happy this freaks him
the hell out and he activates his time
traveling Powers all over again he wakes
up back in the present day moments after
his mother's murder he needs to act fast
he quickly thinks of where to go and
contacts one of his best friends and
goes to hide out at his house but he
then realizes that his face is now in
the news and his friend set him up
trying to ES again he climbs over this
wall but runs into his pizza coworker
iie she tells him that she's been
tracking his phone's GPS and she advises
him to shut it down rescuing him she
takes him back to her house and she
reveals that she thinks he's innocent
and she tells him that she read up on
all the kidnappings that happened to him
when he was a kid and thinks it's
suspicious but satoro realizes in these
old news reports that the exact location
of the second two kidnappings after
kyo's kidnapping has now changed making
him think there is still a chance that
he can go back and save Kyo the next day
satoro stays at her her house while she
heads back to work and acts like
everything is normal however her boss
tells her that he spotted satoro
entering house the day before randomly
but assures her that he hasn't told the
authorities cuz he thinks satoro is
innocent too and she thanks him for not
ranting him out and heads back home and
she has no idea that the Killer is onto
her getting back she tells satoro what
just happened not wanting to risk it he
decides to leave I's house and he tells
her that he'll meet up with her later iy
then decides to bring satoro some fresh
clothes from her house and she gets a
strange text from him telling her to
stay where she is and that's when starts
entering the room as the entire house
violently explodes meanwhile satoru
tries to reach iy as well but realizes
that she hasn't responded to his text
for a while realizing something could be
wrong he rushes on over to check her
house and that's when he sees her place
Up in Flames forcing him to rush inside
and save her barely conscious she slips
her phone inside of his pocket before
she passes out right as their Pizza Boss
shows up helping him Escape before the
police arrive later satoro finds I's
phone in his pocket and discovers the
horrifying text messages that she
received from someone pretending to be
him he realizes that this is the killer
doing and he's likely been following
them this entire time he then heads on
over to meet with his mother's old
journalist colleague and the only friend
he knows this guy who thinks satoro is
actually innocent the journalist reveals
to him that before she died his mother
called him and said that she figured out
the identity of the person behind those
Child Murders 18 years ago she was
supposed to meet with him to talk about
it but never made it the journalist
tells him that he suspects the murder of
the 1988 murders and the death of his
mother was done by the same person who
he thinks is still in the city as they
speak the journalist tell satoro that he
knows how the real killer is operating
by creating additional suspects for his
crimes and delaying the investigation as
a whole it causes eyewitness accounts to
diminish over time and the crime seen as
a whole to deteriorate and because of
this Any Trail for this killer will soon
go cold and this is how he's got away
within all these years he then inspects
I's phone that satoro found and he tells
him that the killer probably tried to
kill her just now too and frame him for
it satoro suspects that this is another
more Sinister reason because satoro was
already the prime suspect of his
mother's murder and the real killer had
nothing to gain from trying to murder iy
he tells journalist guy everything that
happened the day after his mother
stopped that kidnapping attempt within
less than a day his mother died and the
killer knew that he wouldn't be home
which means the killer must have gotten
his work schedule from his pizza job and
have somehow gained access to head into
the back of the restaurant to find it
and this is likely when he meant iie who
would have been working at that time she
must have seen his face at this point as
a result but didn't say anything because
she knew him or he had access to the
rest from beforehand oo this is a big
deal all of these factors that we
already make to this plot twist is so
freaking obvious the killer trying to
murder ireri here confirms what satoru
and US think we know the serial killer
knows we know about him the journalist
told us that the Killer's crimes has
spanned decades and it's clear he's a
pro and know what he's doing and we are
just some pizza delivery guy with a
really handy power but what makes this
killer more terrifying is that he was
spotted in the parking lot about to
commit another kid murder despite the
fact that Japan doesn't have a statute
of limitations for crimes that are
punishable by the death penalty this
means that any crime bad enough like
murder will forever be active even if
you caught 40 years later you will still
go to prison and die this killer could
have been chilling after his last crime
back in 1988 and never got caught so
here's what we know the killer knows who
iriri is where she lived and he also
knew where our mother was staying and
him striking Irey in this case as well
makes it pretty clear that he knows our
addresses statistically serial killers
generally kill within a single Comfort
area a place where they're intimately
familiar with all the details and so
from these signs I'm deducing that this
serial killer not only lives in the city
but also works here and is intimately
connected with our inner circle of
friends and or acquaintances or has
business with the pizza restaurant that
we work at if satoro broke the facts
down like this then I guarantee that
figuring out the identity of this guy
would have been way easier satoro then
gets a phone call from an unknown number
and discovers its iy that she just
escapes the hospital to avoid getting
interrogated by the police and tells him
to meet her under a bridge where satoro
is currently living and heads out to
meet her reaching the bridge she tells
him what he thinks she knows knows and
reveals that earlier she bumped into a
stranger before she left work and
overheard that his name was Nishi zono
and from the badge he was wearing she
thinks this killer is a city councelor
and sat Toro thinks his name is likely
fake and that's when the cops show up to
arrest him and iie realizes that she was
being followed the police quickly arrest
him on the way to the police car he
notices from the corner of his eye the
same man he passed by at his house right
before his mother was murdered and now
knows the real killer is watching him in
real time anxiety starts flooding his
system knowing this is his last shot
through sheer force of will he activates
his powers to take him back in time to
the year of the Child Murders for the
third time but this time he's now landed
back into the museum and he experiences
Deja Vu and realizes that he's back at
the same timeline as the first time but
now has only one day until kyo's murder
this is his last shot to save Kyo and
everyone else the next day at school one
of soro's friends named Kenya tells him
that he's noticed a strong change in him
over the last few weeks and he reveals
he knows that he's been trying to
protect Kyle from her being family
because he's seen her bruises and this
has inspired him to become a stronger
person as well well seeing the oh so
convenient anime timing of it all he
then decides that he needs an ally G you
think to protect Kyo and he lets Kenya
in on what's really going on and how Kyo
will soon be murdered and these two join
forces to protect her satoro tries to
establish a timeline of what's going to
happen he must not leave Kyo in the park
tomorrow which is March 1st but in the
last time Loop she was also murdered the
day after their birthday and that's when
his friend Yuki will be framed for her
murder this means that Yuki first one
needs an alibi so was they do he heads
off to meet him for their regular
hangout session and figures out that he
regularly passes by Kyo on the street
but doesn't really know her and this
makes satoro think that the killer must
have seen them together one day by
chance and this is why Yuki was targeted
the next day he follows through with his
old plan as before he follows Kyo around
the whole day to prevent her from
getting kidnapped in the park March 2nd
and make sure that she shows up to their
double plant birthday party woo which is
the day after March 3rd however Midway
through the party he sneaks out to go to
Yuki's house to give him an alibi
smashing a rug into their house and this
forces unsuspecting Yuki to to call and
deal with the cops while soro's birthday
party is going on officially giving him
an alibi win-win so he heads back to his
party and satoro coincidentally spots
kyo's mother Crossing this bridge and
boy he thinks real long and hard about
pushing her off of the stairs murdering
her himself but that's when Kenya shows
up to stop him and he tells satoru that
he's been following him and tells him
that he's not a murderer and they should
try to save Kyo the right way agreeing
they decide to work together to stop
kyo's mother from hurting her coming up
with a plan to save Kyo tonight they
head back to satoru's party which after
the party ends satoro and Kenya escort
Kyo back to her house but tell her that
him and Kenya have come up with a plan
to save her from her mother without
telling her about the killer she becomes
desperate and she agrees to go along
with the plan that they have and he
leads her to this abandoned bus by their
school and he tells her she should hide
here for the next few days while he
comes to visit her when he's free he
then later returns to visit her and
brings her some food to keep her fed and
Alive until after March 3rd preventing
kyo's second murder later that morning
satoru and Kenya act normal and head to
school noting that kyo's mom also has
hasn't called the police yet interesting
and so Toro then revisualization
by her mother he realizes that Kyle has
lived throughout this day and the
actions of her parents have now changed
this means that everything that happens
now will be completely new that night
sat Toro tells some of his close friends
where kaao is and what's going on and
they go to hang out with her in the bus
and he assures them that he will take
the full blame of everything don't worry
he's a good guy he'll take the fall but
all of his friends tell him that hey
they don't care since they're having fun
in a bus so he tells them that he will
drop by kyo's house tomorrow morning
forcing kyo's mother to finally call the
cops on her disappearance however that
night someone enters the bus and Ka
wakes up but realized that she's behind
this curtain which means she hasn't been
discovered and she holds her breath just
as the mysterious person makes noise on
the other side and then leaves the next
day satoro wakes up early and sneaks out
to check on Kyle before school he gives
her some breakfast and reassures her
that this will be all over in a day or
two heading to class satoru's teacher Mr
Yoshi asks him about Kyle since he's
seen them hanging out and tells him that
he's informed the child where of her
office about her disappearance since he
hasn't heard anything from her mother so
him and them go to kyo's house later to
see what's going on he offers forc
satoro to tag along and this makes him
super happy that his teacher in this
timeline is actively trying to help him
out after school they reach kyo's house
but no one answers with no other options
Mr yoshiro enters kyo's house forcefully
seeing it empty but he notices the
heater is still on and reveals that
Kyle's mother was just here the welfare
officer asks the teacher if they should
call the police but he tells them to
hold off because he has an idea of where
she might be so Toro overhearing this
outside rushes back to the bus to update
Kyle and the others what's going on Kyle
then hands him a late birthday present a
first for any timeline a so sweet she
also tells him about the man that came
last night and asks him to stay the
night with her in case the man comes
back telling him that she heard him kick
some boxes last night and seemed angry
saturo then looks for the destroyed box
around the bus and spots one in the
corner opening it and sees what's inside
holy tools for kidnapping children
the others take time to figure it out
and everyone realizes that they're right
in the middle of the kidnappers
territory and satoro remembers that
tonight is the night of Kyle's murder
satoro then realizes that he needs to
change his plan right now in order to
save her and tells Kyo to stay with his
family tonight instead heading back
satoru's mother lets her stay for the
night and informs the teacher that Kyo
is with her and they come up with a plan
to save her the next night Kyo heads
back home but this time accompanied by
satoru kyo's mother freaks her boobs off
and accuses them of stealing Kyo she
grabs a shovel and she tries to slice
sato's mother's head off almost hits her
and then she tries to get Kyle but
that's when a child welfare officer
shows up and catches her in the ACT they
accuse Kyle's mother of not calling
anyone for her missing child and they
bring out their special weapon kyo's
grandmother granny begs kyo's mother to
forgive her for not being there when she
was young and says she would take care
of Kyle for the time being and she
breaks down in tears and everyone makes
up blah blah blah blah it's all whatever
move on anyways Mr teacher man
congratulates satoro on a job well done
and then he has a real father son moment
with him it's really cool and the
teacher takes Kyo and her grandmother in
the car to start a new life with Kyo
save satoro now focuses his attention on
saving the other two soon to be murder
victims hiromi and Aya who both go to
the school next door and he has to make
sure that they're not left alone and he
notes that a often hangs out with Yuki
and unfortunately she's going to be
harder to keep tabs on the next day
after class he goes to the school next
door to check on the second murder
victim ya and takes note of her routine
and daily schedule but runs into his
mother who forces him to help her with
groceries and they coincidentally meet
Mr teacher man again good old yoshiro
who offers them a ride home and satoro
spying plans for the day get ruined and
he loses one more precious day to save
his friends gee I love this guy's mom
but I hate this mom right now this is
stupid look our plan would not have been
ruined if we just did one simple thing
it's got to do with friendship let me
explain satoro here sucks at telling
people because in reality there's a way
easier way of doing this people tend to
return to the spots that they visited
before which means if you think about it
even if we don't know a that well she's
a part of our age group social class and
background meaning her life is not going
to be that different than ours it means
that she's probably headed home for
dinner during this time which means
following her would not be that hard of
course Woody didn't take into account
was that his mom would ruin his plans
and this highlights his critical mistake
Kenya knew about Kyo which means telling
him about this wouldn't have been that
hard either especially if we told him
the full story that as telling him the
whole picture would have made our claims
seem more reliable by tag taming on this
job it means that we could keep an eye
on her it would have been way easier
because in reality the killer would have
just kidnapped her in a crowded place he
would have lured away into an alley or a
dark area first in the car satoro
accidentally finds a bunch of candy
hidden in a glove box and Mr T yoshiro
quickly confesses that the candy helps
him since he recently quits smoking and
satoro doesn't really care it's candy
the next day satoro sees hiromi and
offers to walk him home but Kenya notic
him being weird again just like he was
with Kyo and confronts him about it he
forces him to reveal the truth that he
thinks the kidnapper isn't done and will
try to kill more people and the stud
ends up believing him anyways and agrees
to help him save the two they head back
to check on the boss that Kaio stay in
but discover that it's now been cleared
out by someone adult-sized Footprints
are leading out of the bus and they
wrapped in cloth and they realized that
the killer did this to avoid leaving
distinct marks so Toro warns in that the
Killer is exclusively targeting children
the next day they go to find a and
soro's friend Kazu convinces her to come
check out their Clubhouse Kenya and
satoro realized that their friend and a
are getting along well making them think
that Kazu unknowingly is solving their
ya problem naturally which is great and
he starts to wonder if this means that
the killer will begin to find new
targets and remembers his mother
recognized the killer which means she
must already know who the Killer is
right now with a being taken care of
they focus on protecting hiromi next but
they find out that the class bully from
earlier Mis has started to become more
alone than usual since the lunch money
incident she's become cut off from the
rest of the class and now hangs out
alone potentially making her the next
murder victim so Satur kicks his new
plans into high gear and begins
following her around town trying to
figure out her schedule my just like a
stalker that's disturbing he follows her
to their class hockey stadium and there
he sees her go to the toilet and satoro
waits for her outside but realizes that
she's taking an unusually long time to
come out that's when Mr teacher yoshiro
bumps into him and he tells satoro that
he's here to cheer for the class game
and asks satoro what he's doing waiting
outside the women's bathroom satoro says
that he's waiting for Mis but Mr yoshiro
tells him that she already left they
hear a truck drive out past them and Mr
Yoshua tells him that he saw misato
leave in it sat Toro notices the truck
belonging to Yuki's father and is
confused why she would be in it pressed
for time he asks his confused teacher to
help him follow her and he'll tell him
about it on the way in the car satoro
tells his teacher what him and his
friends are up to but covers it up with
a little bit of a lie and tells him that
they're playing a game where they
pretend they a kidnapper on the loose
that targets loner children and they
must try and stop him thankfully Mr
yoshiro believes him and tells him to
fasten his seat belt and sooro tries to
log it in but sees a jammed and his
teacher tells him that it's been acting
up lately Mr Yoshua tells him that he
can tell he's taking this game very
seriously this must mean why he's been
acting so differently from the last few
weeks he asks him how he found misato
here and satoro tells him that hiroi
told him she'd be here but he sometimes
feel bad for using people in this game
and Mr yoshiro tells him that he
shouldn't feel guilty because doing good
and bad Deeds are the two sides of the
same coin creeping satoru out he goes on
about how he also has done similar
things recently in order to try and get
close to someone and he mentions how
much fun this has been for him so Toro
asks if he wants a candy opening up the
glove box but then notices a box of
laxatives in there instead as they go
through this tunnel Mr yoshiro tells him
that this isn't his car and confesses
that satoro is playing this game as if
there's a real kidnapper on the loose
how amusing and he tells him that he
can't believe he's been able to read his
thoughts and suddenly makes a sharp turn
away from Yuki's family's truck
revealing to satoro that miso isn't here
but he still at The Honky stadium and
satoro begins to sweat he tells him that
he has no idea that satoro was onto him
until the day he ran into him snooping
on a because that was the day he was
going to murder her revealing that he
planned to see if Soro was really on to
him he was the one who taught miso to
start going to watch hockey games and
told homi about it he even ordered food
Parcels from Yuki's family's business
all planned to set up satoro reaching
this iced River satoro tries to escape
but his well seat belt is jammed Mr
yoshiro tells him that he admires how we
found about him and comments that it's
almost like he can see the future and
takes out a baseball taking out a
basketball from his bag behind he places
it on the gas pedal forcing satoro to go
down with the car and it sinks into the
river about to drown satoro accidentally
yells out to yoshiro that he knows what
lies in his future and he passes out
satoro wakes up then out of nowhere
somehow in the hospital and can't
remember how he got here or what
happened the doctors tell him that he's
been in coma for 15 years but his mother
has been keeping his body active all
this time so he stayed pretty fit he's
also made the news later he gets visits
from his childhood friends Kenya homi
and even Kyle who is now married and has
a son with homi what the what playing
with a baby in Touchin he accidentally
receives all of his memories about his
powers who he is and the horrifying
events that he was trying to stop later
he gets a visit from his old teacher Mr
tii te yoshiro satoro pretends that he
doesn't recognize him and he tells Soro
who he is and that he is now a city
counselor who got married and changed
his name to his wife's family's name
taking over their family business he
tells Soro that they've been through a
lot together and he's been waiting for
him to awaken for 15 years and he's
going to wait patiently until he gets
his memory back back because well they
need to talk the days pass by and satoro
gains his strength back and Kenya and
hiromi visit him more and more but Kenya
tells satoro that he's gotten all his
Memories Back already forcing him to
confess that since so many years have
passed most of the evidence about what
really happened is probably gone there's
no point in bringing anybody else into
this mess Kenyon then lays on some good
old Bromance on him and tells him that
homi became a doctor because he visited
satoru so many times in the hospital
when they were younger and he also
became a lawyer and is still actively
trying to find satoru's attacker that's
how much their friendship meant to them
they beg satoro to not fight alone as he
did when they were young and convince
him to let them in on the full story
revealing to them that Mr teacher
yoshiro is the real killer and they come
up with a plan to stop him along with
his mom who can tell that his memories
have returned and he lets her in on the
truth as well it's game time a few days
later satoro arranges to meet Mr yoshiro
and asks if they can talk privately away
from reporters he takes him to the roof
tapping his fingers on his wheelchair
reaching it satoro confesses that he's
regained his memories but Mr Yoshua
tells him he knows because when he
tapped his finger on his wheelchair
seconds earlier he noticed him Flinch
like he was on alert with both of their
cards on the table Mr yoshiro demands to
know how he predicted all of his moves
because a regular kid would not have
been able to do any of this and asks
what he meant when he said he could see
his future he tells sataro that he knows
he's also recording this conversation
and forces him to hand it over telling
him to try and stop him it's pointless
and Reveals His horrifying plans for him
Saro tells him that he knows he won't
kill him because he would have been dead
already he then lunges off the roof
forcing Mr yoshiro to save him from
falling sooro then tells him that he is
the only one that gives meaning to his
life and he is the only one who truly
knows the real him and this makes Mr
yoshiro start crying as he lets satoro
fall and announces that he can't live
without him either and he prepares to
kick a bucket too about to jump he spots
satoro down below still alive surrounded
by all of his teammates and realizes
that he's been set up oh Good Golly G
this might seem great I instead would
have relied on this 2006 digital
camcorder in order to stop Mr Yoshi let
me explain the plan they just pulled off
was way worse than that one time it's
known from beforehand that yosher here
is a real cunning serial killer and
doesn't leave evidence of his crimes and
fra others this guy wants to murder kids
because he wants to spare them a life of
hardship and pain basically thinks he's
a God and this means that this psycho
and US putting ourselves in this
vulnerable position even if it paid off
was stupid their grand solution not only
seemed rush but risky and had way too
many variables and things could have
gone so wrong what they should have done
unlike yoshiro we had a whole team which
means that I could have been less risky
and could have kept a fiveman rotation
at the hospital at all times near sato's
hospital room and would have also placed
a few small recording cameras in there
like these digital flip video cameras
hidden around his backup having our
teammates take shift outside or near
sato's door for half day intervals would
have allowed us to look for yoshiro
incoming 24/7 and we could have also
suddenly banged on the door to give an
off a sign to tip him off and let him
know that he was in the area preventing
Yoshua from getting us until we
discovered enough to get out of here in
order to properly stop him or could have
caught him in the act of trying to kill
us through our cameras and phones placed
around the room Yoshua quickly gets
arrested for attempted murder and the
day is saved over the next few years so
Toro ends up becoming a successful manga
artist and notices that his powers
haven't been activated since the day he
saved everyone taking break from another
day at work he goes by for a walk
passing by the same Bridge he once hid
from the cops under and there he spots a
blue butterfly past him and a stranger
runs into him and asks if she can take
shelter from the snow with him and she
takes off her beanie and saturo
recognizes who it is Irey but what do
you guys think about the video don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
thumbs up down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist